Wayne Right with eight to shoot back to
KD with six Durant driving on Hardaway
pull-up jumper Durant got it and Phoenix
has a two-point lead 35 for Durant this
is just
that takes you off to dribble give you
the fake and then create the space and
then the size I'm going to shoot up over
the top of excellent defense and Frey
coming in for defense here Dallas ball
down two 11 seconds left here's Luca
Duncan striving spinning on a Kobe
getting deep creating space missed the
shop Durant gets the rebound Don just
was upset he missed the shot that he
didn't foul the rat until another second
one off the clock and now Durant will
shoot free throws it Devin Booker and
doncico face to face
you know what it's Wainwright has to
step in the officials haven't called
anything yet
well I'll tell you what Booker started
that Booker was yapping as jokic was
that was down and depressed that he
missed that shot and all of a sudden he
just straightened up and went right
after Booker
Durant with a big smile on his face
as he comes back down the court let's
see if the officials as they reviewed
things call technicals at all here
you see Durant getting the rebound after
the Miss by dunches then he commits the
foul
now just watch he's upset now you can
see right there you see Booker he's
yapping at him right now and that caused
that caused that incident right there
and
The Dallas Players are still crowding
the foul line where Durant was wanting
to take the free throws the officials
have to separate more players
this may take a while they got to look
at a lot here
game not over I mean Durant said the
line shooting too but they have a
timeout so they can advance the ball if
he were to miss one of these two or both
look Dallas got what they wanted they
came out and they ran the situation it
was a clear out and then the move like
dancing down inside unfortunately the
ball did knock on the bed all right then
all of a sudden after that you could see
we just got finished showing you that
now keep an eye right
so here's the thing he'll be if they
call Double T's it's one thing but if
they call it technical on donchic and
not Booker
now you have more opportunities
obviously hit free throws and put this
game Out Of Reach if you're Phoenix
well there's it's definitely Booker was
yapping
as notches was
showing us a little sorrow about missing
that play okay and you see doncic with
the retaliatory move physically to the
verbal yeah now watch see watch it right
now now what you see you're going to see
him see he's yapping at him right there
I think he's talking to Eric Lewis the
official I wonder if he's saying that
should have been a foul on donchic
against Tori Craig and Luca didn't like
that so he went after Booker
right if you miss one and you get the
rebound you call time out and still
you'll still have an opportunity there
but Durant is the best free-throw
shooter in the NBA and unfortunately he
now has 36 points now he's leading the
league over 90 all year long
36 34 for Luca big free throw Durant hit
it four point game timeout Jason Kidd
he'll be able to advance the ball here
but they Trail by four with three and a
half seconds left and that's